rachid est un fidèle du marché de noël
de tours depuis 14 ans il y vend ses
pâtisseries orientales boulevard
heurteloup cette année changement
d'adressé son chalet et place de la
résistance
les tourangeaux et vont venir vous voir
le marché de noël partout dans quatre
coins du tout à ça veut dire dans quatre
coins de tours centre comme ça tout le
tous les commerçants ils vont bénéficier
de la clientèle de tout le monde ça sera
pas bloqué seulement toujours sur le
boulevard heurteloup pour ce marché de
noël version qu'ovide 37 chalet occupé
contre une soixantaine l'an dernier est
réparti en quatre endroits sur le
boulevard lieux historiques du rendez
vous les avis sont mitigés
il est pas mal mais je pense que qui
sont éparpillés aux qu'ils soient
concentrés au même endroit ça fait
exactement la même chose je trouve
tristoune l île minuscule comparé aux
autres années il n'y a personne
et puis le teint pas de la partie donc
l'esprit ne niait pas c'est pourtant le
seul compromis qu'a trouvé la mairie
pour organiser l'événement d'abord
annulé à l'annonce dur confinement en
moins d'une semaine
il a fallu retrouver des exposants
certains n'ont pas eu le temps de se
retourner il n'avait pas prévu de
reprendre un marché de noël il avait pas
les stocks etc
donc les commerçants que vous voyez là
c'est vraiment une majorité de
commerçants locaux mais qui n'avait pas
beaucoup de trajets à faire et qui
s'était aussi un souhait de notre part
de dd
les commerçants de la touraine certains
commerçants de la ville sont même sortis
de leur boutique et loué un chalet c'est
le cas de lucie et marion restauratrice
dans une rue adjacente pour elle c'est
l'opportunité rêvée de reprendre leurs
activités
et c'est aussi un petit peu de reprendre
du galon pour nous parce que pendant
s'ennuie comme tout le monde et ça fait
du bien au moral vraiment et je pense
que c'est dans ces périodes de crise où
il faut et sud se réinventer trouver de
nouvelles idées
il faut transformer le pépin en pépites
et du coup là c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire
donc voilà ça valait le coup ça vaut le
coup d'essayer sur le marché même
protocole que dans les restaurants
interdiction de manger sur place cette
année les douceurs de noël se déguste
quand même mais à emporter